Although using the standard error of the estimate can help us assess the
accuracy of our predictions. We can make even more accurate predictions by
computing confidence intervals for our predicted values, our y-hats. In other
words, when we get our regression line, we have our expected value which is
this y-hat naught, for a specified value x-naught. However, the actual value
might be anything from up here, to down here, or it might be exactly equal to
our predicted value. Therefore, we might want a confidence interval around our
expected value for where the actual value might be. Similarly, we might want a
confidence interval for the true slope. We'll have a certain regression line
and we'll have calculated the slope for that regression line based on our
sample data. And this is just an example, the slope could be this, or flatter
down to here. A confidence interval for a slope can tell us the range for which
the true population's slope might be. You won't actually calculate the
confidence interval in this lesson, because we're going to assume that you'll
use a computer to get it. The important thing is that you know what it means.
For example, let's say we have some sample data that looks like this. We
calculate that the regression line is y equals bx plus a. Some slope and some
intercept. But let's say then that we're able to look at all the population
data. And it looks like this. Now it looks to be slightly downward sloping.
Since we're assuming this is the true regression line, we'll use the common
notation for the regression coefficients for the population. Oh, and these
should have hats since they're the predicted values. If this were the case,
where the sample regression line is positively sloping. But the true regression
line for the population is negatively sloping. That would mean that the
confidence interval for b has a negative lower bound and a positive upper
bound. It includes zero within this range. Therefore, if we run a two-tailed
hypothesis test for whether or not the slope is equal to zero. We would fail to
reject the null, meaning there's no evidence that there's a linear relationship
between x and y based on that sample. In fact, let's get more into hypothesis
testing for slope.